bonjour messieurs dames
pour ma part aujourd'hui je vais tenter
de vous convaincre que l'on peut avancer
tout en faisant du surplace alors pour
vous expliquer comment j'y suis parvenu
je vais devoir vous parler un petit peu
de moi donc il faut savoir que je suis
psychologue cogner titien j'ai appris
dans mes études comment un expert
devient un expert et ce qui est amusant
c'est que dans ma vie personnelle j'ai
pu découvrir de façon très inattendue
comment devenir un expert dans des
choses tout aussi inattendue alors avant
en 1998 j'avais huit ans et j'ai rêvé
que j'étais capable de faire du vélo en
marche arrière alors du coup le
lendemain matin je monte sur mon vélo je
m'assois sur le guidon prêt à partir en
marche arrière
et là pas de magie un patatras je tombe
mais j'ai persévéré persévérer percée et
six mois plus tard j'étais capable de
faire du vélo en marche arrière
j'ai appris à mes à mes amis à faire du
vélo en marche arrière et en 2000
j'ouvre le guinness des records
et je découvre qu'un canadien matthew
winter a fait 50 km en marche arrière
du coup je vais voir le maire de ma
ville pour le téléthon en 2001 et je
vais proposer essayer de battre ce
canadien et il se trouve qu'à 13 ans je
deviens recorman du monde du 50 km
marche arrière
merci alors vous pouvez vous demander à
quoi ça sert tout ça ce qui est amusant
c'est que ça m'a ouvert plein de
nouvelles perspectives
j'ai appris ensuite à jongler j'ai
appris à faire du monocycle et puis j'ai
poursuivi mes études et en 2011 je suis
diplômée de psychologie cognitive
donc ma spécialité c'est la didactique
professionnel sait comment est-ce qu'un
expert apprend son métier et derrière
les des aaa à transmettre son savoir aux
novices tu es tu
une fois diplômé je n'ai pas décidé de
devenir consultant dans la foulée j'ai
décidé de voyager
je suis parti en irlande
et à mon retour je propose à un ami qui
était capable de gagner sa vie dans la
rue en jonglant sur mon monastique
je propose de partir en vacances sur la
côte d'azur et de deux de passer de
bonnes vacances
au bout de dix jours il rentre à la
maison et je vais essayer de faire comme
lui de jongler dans la rue et il se
trouve qu'au bout de cinq semaines
j'ai suffisamment d'argent pour partir à
hawaii et en australie alors pourquoi
hawaï et pourquoi l'australie c'est
parce qu'en fait j'avais envoyé un vélo
de collection un passionné hawaïen d'une
soixantaine d'années laurine six mois
plus tôt et en fait il m'avait dit
clémente a réalisé le rêve de ma vie je
vais envoyer le vélo sur lequel il
roulait 30 ans plus tôt hawaï et du coup
il m'a dit tu viens quand tu veux à la
maison
donc je pars hawaï il m'offre un super
vol en hélicoptère bref je passe cinq
semaines de folie hawaï et je découvre à
la fois les terres hawaïenne la beauté
des paysages mais aussi la culture
hawaïenne
ensuite je pars pour l'australie je
rejoins un ami qui avait acheté un van
et qui me propose de faire un tour
d'australie
donc je le dis je le bien venir mais il
faut que tu acceptes que je fasse des
spectacles de rue sur notre route
banco il accepte et à mon retour en
france je me rencontre qui manque une
dimension à mon voyage en australie j'ai
l'impression de pas vraiment avoir
voyagé je me suis énormément déplacée
j'ai fait plus de 25000 km là bas et
pourtant il ya un petit bémol et grâce à
mon voyage précédent lounge je me rends
compte qu'il a manqué la dimension
humaine il a manqué la rencontre est
donc à partir de ce jour je décide de
voyager tout le temps en déplaçant chez
l'habitant
et là coup du sort dans ma vie je me
fait renverser par une voiture alors
généralement pour un sportif un accident
mènent généralement à la fin d'une
carrière
et bien moi ça me la crée je m'explique
passionné de vélo comme je suis je
continue à faire du vélo
même blessé au genou gauche et au feu
rouge bas âge et la jambe tendue et du
coup j'apprends à faire du surplace sur
un seul pied le truc c'est que deux mois
plus tard il ya les championnats du
monde de coursiers à vélo à lausanne en
suisse
et il se trouve qu'il ya une épreuve de
surplace en vélo lors de ces
championnats du monde
donc au bout de deux minutes en
équilibre sur le vélo je vais vous faire
une petite démonstration au bout de deux
minutes en équipe sur le vélo on nous
demande d'ôter et donc au bout de deux
minutes en équipe sur le vélo pour nous
corse et la tâche on nous demande d'ôter
notre casque de course y avait eu notre
sac à dos et notre petit shirt donc au
départ de l'épreuve on était à peu près
80 et ensuite on nous demande d'ôter les
mains et pour le final on ne demande
d'ôter un pied à ce moment là tout le
monde est tombé et grâce à suite cet
accident en fait j'ai tenu trente
secondes en équilibre sur un seul pied
et je suis devenu champion du monde sur
place en vélo et là j'avais un travail
j'avais une copine j'avais ma vie et
coups du sort je me fais virer ma copine
se bat pareil
et du coup je fais le constat j'ai la
voiture de mon grand père j'ai mon vélo
mon titre de champion du monde et un
besoin cruel de repartir en voyage
et là j'ai l'idée le 25 décembre 2013 y
un peu plus d'un an de partir au cap
nord à l'aventuré en norvège
et tous les soirs de prendre mon vélo
sur l'épaule et d'aller frapper aux
portes chez l'habitant et dire aux gens
si vous m'invitez ce soir pour m'aider à
rejoindre le cap nord et bien je vous
offre un spectacle de surplace en vélo
dans votre salon donc ça peut paraître
surprenant mais j'ai fait ça plus de 500
fois dans 15 pays
donc là je peux vous présentez
marguerite 84 ans c'est là c'est la
première de mes hôtes à avoir joué le
jeu voilà c'était en belgique le 24
février 2014 et tous les soirs
voilà je changeais de deux maisons j'ai
fait des rencontres incroyables
j'ai dormi en norvège chez des éleveurs
de rennes j'ai rencontré des parages
east j'ai fait toutes sortes de
rencontre complètement incroyable j'ai
même été contactés au retour de ce
voyage en norvège par une équipe de
france 2 car fait un petit reportage
pour pour le tour de france et à richard
virenque qui m'a contacté pour que je la
jouais pour le roc d'azur à ses couleurs
il ya une équipe de basket de proa qui
m'a contacté pour que je la jouais à la
mi temps d'un match
bref c'était c'est fabuleux ça roule et
oui excusez moi et là je décide de ne ne
pas m'arrêter là parce qu'en fait je me
suis rendu compte dans ce voyage en
norvège que la rencontre les rencontres
avait fait toute la magie de ceux de ce
voyage est donc j'entreprends un nouveau
projet qui va mener beaucoup moins loin
en terme de distance mais toujours aussi
riche en terme de rencontres et du coup
toujours aussi riche en terme de voyages
et là je m'engage dans un tour de france
je suis actuellement en fait j'ai fait
un virage mais je suis en plein tour de
france des communes aux noms insolites
voilà je suis parti il ya 81 jours et ça
fait 80 nuit que je dors chez l'habitant
tous les soirs je m'arrête dans une
commune au nom insolite en présentant
comme ça aux habitants avec mon gros
plus en jaune donc ça c'était dans le
salon de montcuq donc voilà alors ils
ont battu le record c'est pour ça que je
vous la montre ils ont battu le record
de spectateurs dans le salon 25
spectateurs
ça c'était ave rue voilà avec toujours
aussi conviviale je suis passé à la
mouiller je suis passé donc voir le
maire de montcuq le maire de charlie je
me passe de commentaire et en fait tous
les jours je pars avec ma petite voiture
électrique
voilà je vais de de ville en ville et je
fais des rencontres complètement
incroyable complètement improbable et le
voyage est une richesse complètement
complètement folle voilà et si je dois
tirer un enseignement de tout ça c'est
que il n'y a pas forcément besoin de
faire beaucoup de distance pour voyager
pour pour profiter de la vie et toutes
les ressources qui sont autour de nous
et je pense que je viens de vous
démontrer
on peut avancer sur place merci
mieres chaussures je croyais un
placement en dessous la yeah allez c'est
parti pour la seconde chaussure y ait en
avant pour les chaussettes de mamie
jeanine y est c'est pas pratique
yep est maintenant en avant pour la
chemise beau temps y est
allez c'est parti yep et enfin messieurs
dames pour le clou du spectacle où vous
y avez cru est aussi en avant pour le
pantalon est ce que vous êtes chaud
bouillant allez c'est parti pour la
première jambe avec la sphère ça colle
allez on y croit c'est vraiment chouette
à lui toujours tort
tu es prêt à temps je me rapproche de
l'écrou là allez c'est parti
centration exécutions y est allez c'est
parti pour la seconde jambe y est merci
beaucoup